[Musik]
thomas stocker ist derzeit ein gefragter
mann
denn es gab einen rekordsommer und das
thema klimawandel ist in aller munde war
uns die soma sieht auch 264 und die
tiere häufig ist das ganz klare logik
von manch machte klimawandel
[Musik]
klimaforscher denken in jahrhunderten
medienberichten über einzelereignisse
stocker und seine kollegen sollen dann
jeweils erklären wie es so weit kommen
konnte und wie es weitergeht
kein zufall dass stockers erster
auftritt im schweizer fernsehen 19 95
war ein jahr nach dem rekordsommer von
1994 stürme werden heftiger und gewitter
entladen sich immer früher im jahr am
stärksten leiden bei uns die berge
regionen erdrutsche und nur gänge sind
die folgen abschmelzen der gletscher und
auftauen der dauerfrost hänge folgen der
zunehmenden erwärmung 1994 war das
heißeste jahres in der schweiz jemals
registriert worden ist die temperaturen
lagen je nach region bis zu drei grad
über dem durchschnitt
die klimaforscher am physikalischen
institut der uni bern sind weltweit
führend wie interpretiert professor
thomas stocker die wette anomalien
kenntnis von der physik und der biologie
vom klimasystem macht es sehr
wahrscheinlich dass optik extremereignis
und ihre häufig verknüpft sie könnten
mit menschlicher macht der
klimaveränderungen
hmm
[Musik]
heute ist stoff für eine re weltweit
renommiertesten und einflussreichsten
klimaforscher er ist an die ostküste
grönlands gereist
nach ilulissat wo über den aufbau eines
internationalen forschungs haupt
diskutiert wird der klimaforschung auf
internationalem spitzenniveau betreiben
wolle der brauche politischen gut will
geld und zugang zu grünland sagt stocker
hier ist der hotspot der forschung zum
klimawandel
wir wollen die dynamik und das schicksal
dieses schildes verstehen
neben klimaforscher sind auch diplomaten
des eda angereist die politik profitiert
von wissenschaftlern stocker die
spitzenforschung öffnet der politik
türen etwa zum arktischen rat einem
forum bestehend aus den anrainerstaaten
des nordpols darunter die usa und
russland
dass er da spricht von wissenschafts
diplomatie vereinte sieht der wird man
politik machen wo viel mehr vor der
wissenschaft oder fakten inspiriert ist
dass man es aufgrund
vorwissenschaftliche research und
erkenntnis was für politik dass man muss
machen
aber auf der anderen seite und das ist
vielleicht vorschnell interessant dass
man seit wir durch wissenschaft quasi
wie als hintertür benutzer im positiven
sinne zu blutungen die schule bringen wo
eigentlich so stellt damit ein anderer
der trainer nicht unter griechischem
ersetzen
darum wird hier auch aufstocker
angestoßen
unter klimaforschern ist der 59 jährige
vater von zwei erwachsenen töchtern
unumstritten für sogenannte klima
kritiker indes eine reizfigur
dass es wärmer wird das bestreitet nicht
dass co2 in fluss oft eher der wärme hat
bestritten immer das ist ja absolut der
konsens des frage nun eher stockend
frage ist nur wie groß ist der fluss und
ist der fluss in dem sinn katastrophe
steht wenn ich mir den rat obwohl ich da
die jünger bin also der verlage sie sehe
die welt durch ein interview
der kanal der klimawandel ist das größte
problem der gegenwart da geben sie sich
doch erlös wieder geben sie sich als
kampf- und auch die vision der satz die
krieger klimawandel ist eine der größten
herausforderungen der menschheit stadt
integrieren sollen diesen millionen
ich darf doch nur klima konvention
dazu erstellt häufig doch zitiere also
dass ich wie war nicht nur auf die
waldwoche zitieren dass der welt auch
für den bauingenieuren und architekten
paul post ist stocker ein rotes tuch
2007 von boston nach deutschland und
darauf sich in einer autobahnraststätte
namens heiligenroth mit einer gruppe
gleichgesinnter alles zweifel die
meisten naturwissenschaftler für sie
wahr erwiesen dass klimaerwärmung und
co2 nichts miteinander zu tun haben die
da noch mehr über diese herausbringen
und ich denke wir müssen gegen diese
propaganda falscher daten und falscher
zahlen die sich zu einer politischen
ideologie hochstilisiert vorgehen der
schlusspunkt war die formulierung eines
manifests die teilnehmer ringen um die
richtigen worte
das war klimaschutz sieht man kann kein
klima china ja das müssen sie es lieber
kam ein schützender zwar war das klima
manifest von heiligenroth gibt es noch
immer bossert seinen achtzigsten und ist
überzeugter denn je dass uns die
klimaforscher an der nase herumführen ab
89 studierte an der eth chemie physik
und klima studiert und bietet das keine
theorie funktioniert doch vom
klimawandel tötet sie locker sich co2
und das ja wie vor morgens sollte dass
die meisten klimaforscher haben dass das
interne klima forscher dass ihm
behauptet
zum beispiel thomas stocker dass er
einen behaltet ihr vertreten
die behaupten einfacher bis und können
das nicht belegte und es ist so dass es
keinen physikalischen effekt gibt
der zeigt dass die änderung der
konzentration des spurengase zb die
temperatur eines bodennahen gasbereich
verändert
es gibt also diesen sogenannten
atmosphärischen co2 treibhauseffekt
nicht
diese behauptung sei durch tausende von
wissenschaftlichen studien klar
widerlegt sagt stocker eine weitere
diskussion reine zeitverschwendung
stocker studierte an der eth zürich
umweltphysik und legte eine steile
karriere hin
er wurde professor an der uni bern und
eine prägende figur im weltklimarat
einem gremium der uno dass sich unter
anderem mit den folgen globaler
erwärmung für umwelt und gesellschaft
befasst
da die berichte des weltklimarates die
grundlage für die globale klimapolitik
sind sein einfluss also enorm ist werden
an ihn höchste ethische anforderungen
gestellt waren genauso um ist ein klarer
dass natur sehr stark interessiert und
vor allem natur zerstört physikalische
mathematische methoden als instrument
für das verständnis zu ca das habe ich
immer faszinieren
nein
den aktuellen vorsitzenden des
weltklimarates beurteilt stocker
kritisch man dachte das sei eine
funktion mit einem starken
wissenschaftlichen element aber man sah
dass es immer politischer wurde die
ganze klimadebatte auch das ist eine
sehr sichtbare position wenn man sich
ein sichtbar macht cacciari machte sie
sichtbar
aber er ist über dummheiten und vorwürfe
gestolpert die rede ist von roger and
rubber cherry dem ex chef des
weltklimarates und von vorwürfen
sexueller belästigung der pc sie
brauchte einen neuen vorsitzenden
stocker war der wissenschaftlich
kompetenteste kandidat gewählt wurde der
südkoreaner sung lee
die südkoreaner haben diese wahl
gewonnen denn sie haben bei ihrer
kampagne ein bisschen nachgeholfen
gekaufte stimmen bei der wahl des eu
vorsitzes vor malerischer kulisse klotzt
eine bombe
ich will es genau wissen
die wahl ist voll aufgegangen
ein anderes sagen zu können sind auch
direkte hilfe versprochen wurde
jedes land hat ja stimme sondern auch
für seine position
peter hartz war wie direkte kontakt
zwischen der hersteller untereinander zu
hier stehen wir sichere einheitlich sie
in seiner bestätigt gegenüber reportern
südkorea habe sich die wahl tatsächlich
etwas kosten lassen
der see teils schriftlich mit die wahl
sei nach den richtlinien abgelaufen und
das ergebnis von allen ländern
akzeptiert worden
zurück in der schweiz hat stocker seine
an sich nicht geändert wie qualifiziert
sie da so goldberg stimme da werden doch
sagen dass korruption oder das hatte
auch pack das ist sehr schwierig wird
dann natürlich auch schwierig die
unabhängige wissenschaftliche arbeit
machen wo einmal klima us dollar für
ihren im auftrag von allen andern wenn
es doch natürlich einzelne länder hat wo
dann verpflichtung geltend machen
gegenüber 1 vorsitzender dann wird sehr
schwierig der ip verzichtet auf eine
weitere stellungnahme
[Musik]
zurück in grönland rostockers reise noch
weitergehen
auf einladung von christiane leister
einer vermögenden unternehmerin sie
offerierte einer gruppe bestehend aus
wissenschaftlern diplomaten und
künstlern eine all inclusive expedition
ziel sich vor ort über den klimawandel
informieren und das erlebte weitertragen
seine lebensumstände hätten sich in den
vergangenen jahren spürbar verändert
erzählt dieser jäger das ziehe sich
immer weiter zurück das mache das jagen
immer schwieriger er führt die gruppe
zum hafen und zu dem was von den gästen
erlebten nach wahlen üblich ist
noch hätten sie genug zu essen aber er
glaube dass die folgen des klimawandels
existenzbedrohend werden könnten
bei uns zweifeln indes weiter viele nur
44 prozent der schweizer glauben dass
der klimawandel menschengemacht ist
bei vielen geht es um verspieltes
vertrauen
[Musik]
immer wieder fällt das stichwort
waldsterben ein phänomen der 19
achtziger jahre
es begann erinnert sich kantons
oberförster schwierig mit massenhaft
absterbenden weiß pannen im unteren
bereich des bannwaldes seit zwei jahren
häufen sich nun auch die schaden- bilder
an der fichte in den höhenlagen das jahr
so stark erschrocken und eigentlich
nicht nur ich sondern ich spiele habe
ich einfach schritte der uci die ent
dass er unbedingt bestätigen
panik machte sich breit zu fifa 12 ist
die heraufbeschworene katastrophe blieb
allerdings aus verbraucher vorher
das hat man den griff indem wir das
schwerelose knall hat also den
reinigungs schritt gemacht hat und die
ware hat sich erholt also das ist nur
den mythos das ist sicher damals
dramatisch dargestellt worden dass man
sagen
aber nun muss auch festhalten
das klimasystem vor gewaltig fast
einfach als zuschauer und quantifizieren
als anwalt vielmehr dass man hat viel
mehr masse temperatur massige mehr hand
die die ganze atmosphäre im weiten ozean
haben und was ihn für die letzten 60
jahre
wo man wirklich knochen festhalten wie
sich das system im globalen maßstab
verwendet hat über viele jahrzehnte die
physikalischen prozessen handel modell
wo das könnte noch bilden und auf eine
wissenschaftliche basis
hat mir enorm viel mehr informationen
als damals über relativ komplexes
ökosystem wald und auf jede unbekannte
hat stocker 30 gruppe nutzt den freien
nachmittag für einen augenschein lokalen
supermarkt
im sortiment sind hundeschlitten die
neuesten iphones 10 wärme und alkoholika
kurz was der grönländer zwischen
tradition und moderne offenbar so
braucht
wir fliegen in zwei charter flugzeug in
richtung norden unser ziel eine
internationale forschungsstation namens
ist grip
ich werde mich auf einem fernen planeten
surreal wunderschön und bitterkalt minus
25 grad
wegen des windes ist die gefühlte
temperatur allerdings tiefe minus 38
grad
stocker und sein team modellieren
vergangene und künftige
klimaveränderungen eisbohrkerne aus
grünland liefern ihnen dafür die basis
mit speziellen bohren drinnen die
forscher bis zu drei kilometer ins ein
schild vor
sie fördern es dass über 100.000 jahre
alt ist
das ergebnis sieht dann so aus für
demonstration
die bohrkerne werden gelagert und später
unter anderem an die uni bern verschickt
verschiedene größen entweder romneys
oder der luft wie sie geschlossen nicht
da haben wir eine einzigartige klima
geschichte schrieb in köln können wir
über 130 jahre zurück doch haben wir
zusätzlich von der atmosphäre
konzentration vor der trikots manchmal
sogar die natürliche klimaschwankungen
und klimavariabilität masse augsburg das
ist eine einmalige klimaarchiv wo die
informationen drin hat aber wie
zuverlässig sind die darauf basierenden
modelle
2007 gab sich stocker selbstbewusst
es kommt regen für eine missione des
rekord waren jahres aber tendenz ist
steigend ganz klar wenn man sich die
letzten zwölf jahre feststellen
dann wurde es immer offensichtlicher
dass die temperaturen nicht mehr wie
vorausgesagt stiegen 19 98 hatte eine
sogenannte klima pause eingesetzt
die temperatur sei stagniert wie kommt
das jetzt zusammen
da darf man nicht verwechseln einen
langfristigen trend seit ende des 19
jahrhunderts ist hört sich die erde um
knapp ein grad erwärmt die 15 jahre die
wir betrachten die haben nichts mit
diesem lang anhaltenden erwärmungstrend
zu tun sondern sind verursacht durch
natürliche schwankungen und
einflussgrößen wie die sonne oder die
staubbelastung in der atmosphäre ganz
verstanden haben wir allerdings diese
phänomene noch nicht das muss man auch
zugeben
kurz darauf dann die erlösung für
stocker wieder ein rekordjahr
[Musik]
die reise geht weiter und weiter und
noch weiter
wir landen an im ferneren orten
[Musik]
unbezahlbare erlebnisse bleibende
eindrücke
[Musik]
auf einladung der passionierten
skifahrerin christiane leister
und sehr co2 intensiv zumal für eine
gruppe die der gesellschaft vermitteln
will
sie möge sich im interesse der natur
doch bitte einschränken
stört das alles überleitung das ist klar
die ganze reis wird kompensiert das
heißt mehr investiert die projekt wo der
co2 ausstoß reduziert wird dem as rom er
das produkt rennt das ist natürlich kein
ablasshandel oder so wer soll denn
sparer vor allem die wo sich die
zertifikate grundleistung gut das ist
einen langsamen übergang im moment war
mir mit dem rückzug und praxis gibt es
keine andere möglichkeit als so
zertifikat oder so projekt zu
unterstützen
natürlich geht's möglichkeit überhaupt
nichts pflege sieht den 38 ist
glaubwürdigkeit problem
ich danke mit mehreren arbeiten wo sich
heute polargebiet abspielt oder einmal
klimarat um sehr viel umkreist sind wenn
man das kompensieren
mit dem zertifikat und projekt wo man
unterstützen und mir betrachtet für was
die optisch denn ich das ksk
wirklichkeit problem
[Musik]
mit anderen worten der zweig in diesem
falle die wissenschaften heiligt die
mittel
[Musik]
aber war stock wirklich zu einem
wissenschaftlichen zweig unterwegs
[Musik]
ja sagt er hier seien zum beispiel in
der forschungsstation ist grip gewesen
[Musik]
mit kollegen einen sprachführer
wasserstand von projekten und hatte sie
können anbieten oder wenn wir nach einem
lied aber ein persönlicher besuch peter
niveau vor ort schaffen auf capri dem
projekt hat auch wichtige persönliche
komponente sagt es ist nur um wissen
aufgaben und danach wie um lobbying um
politisches lobbying einer sitzung dass
sie zwar finanziell das fleisch
natürlich die zukunft könnte die
irgendwie mit kalter beteiligte forscher
allerdings sozialmedizin kann aber der
wissenschaftliches erste ziel ist es
gespräche mit amische
wissenschafterinnen und wissenschafter
und autoren über möglichkeiten sein soft
power
das ist interessant seminar womacka und
in ilulissat und zweite punkt ist sie
auch für die persönliche begegnung mit
der bevölkerung denen verschiedene der
vorstand sehe wie der klimawandel die
rugby wirkt auf ganz europa haben und
ich frage mich wie es mit dem großen
ganzen weitergeht mit der welt den klima
und mit uns allen
[Musik]